c'est une nuit de noël comme les autres
un bonhomme de neige des cadeaux un père
noël
rien ne manque à la tradition
difficile de deviner que cette nuit de
noël se passent ici nous sommes à l'île
de la réunion
en ce mois de décembre il fait plus de
30 degrés la température de l'eau est à
c'est ici que vivent cathy son mari et
leur famille nombreuse six enfants de 4
à 18 ans ce matin la famille a décidé de
profiter de la plage mais pas le temps
de s'éterniser dans quelques jours c'est
noël et cette année katy a décidé de
leur faire vivre un moment très
particulier
un noël comme en métropole les enfants
lauga larissa loris lauriane benjamin
melvin six premières étapes transformer
la maison familiale et les avantages
avec une famille nombreuse c'est que
tout le monde participe
alors l'idée c'est de réaliser en fête
la façade d'un chalet donc ce sera là le
devant donc à rennes porte centrale et
puis les fenêtres sur le côté
ça commence à sentir le sapin déjà c'est
pas trop le droit car cette année cathy
tient à marquer le coup bakcell
particulier parce que j'ai mon grand
garçon qui à beijing qui a 18 ans et
je pense qu'il a des projets d'avenir et
je sais pas combien de noël il lui reste
avec nous je veux que qu'il est vraiment
ce noël en souvenir exactement pas qu'on
voulait éviter
on trace une fenêtre donc j'ai dit on
peint pas la fenêtre elle par la fenêtre
après une journée de peinture difficile
encore de se croire devant un chalet de
montagne
mais katy a plus d'un tour dans son sac
il sait qu'à trouver l'année jusqu'ici à
trouver la neige où cathy a en effet
prévu d'enneiger le petit jardin
familial
il commence à l'insulter vers le foot
lui en a partout et comme avec de la
vraie neige
la petite entreprise familiale se
transforme très vite en bataille rangée
[Musique]
genevois
mikati a vraiment pensé à tout dans le
cas où le père noël n'est pas le temps
de venir jusqu'à la réunion elle
organise un casting de père noël de
remplacement parmi ses voisins savaient
que je sus ouais pas trop pour cathy
l'enjeu est important
les plus petits y croire encore donc je
veux qu'on trouve le père noël qui va
corresponde vraiment qui a fait le plus
vrai possible le deuxième candidat du
mal aussi à convaincre le jury
[Musique]
est ce que tu veux manger jusqu'à
devenir cet ep pour pouvoir
oui on va sûrement drapelets place enfin
aux derniers postulants un père noël
plus couleur locale volait d'enfance le
pineau au super hein je suis pas le
créole avec l'équipe faudra absolument
qui fasse bien son texte on fait un
effort
c'est françois sorel à applaudir
françois déjà
[Musique]
noël c'est ce soir et l'excitation monte
cathy a opté pour un menu ultra
traditionnel saumon foie gras huîtres 1
et l'incontournable bûche de noël a
consommé ici avec certaines précautions
le problème c'est que effectivement avec
la chaleur
ben quand on se met à la bûche mais faut
que je m'assure que tout le monde soit
prêt à manger qu'elle n'est pas que ce
soit la droite à gauche parce que sinon
ça va être une bûche ça va être de la
crème glacée à boire à la paille quoi
la nuit tombe sur l'île de la réunion
chalets en bois sapins enneigés
cathy a réussi à créer l'illusion d'un
noël traditionnels pour l'occasion elle
a convié quelques voisins et un invité
de dernière minute
le père noël créole le cadeau
fait mander lui faire doucement oh la la
il ya très peu d'eau
harris minuit passé il fait encore 24
degrés sur l'île de la réunion
alors pour rafraîchir l'atmosphère
tropicale
rien de mieux qu'un peu de neige même
artificiel
[Musique]